good morning John I don't even know if
you knew this about me but I have a
condition it's called sleep paralysis
very common and it's when you wake up
and camp moves usually happens after
I've had a particularly intense dream
and it's only ever a couple of seconds
from and I woke up in the middle of the
night last night after having a dream in
which Katherine got double pregnant I
don't know if you know about double
pregnancy but according to my dream
anyway it's where a woman who is already
pregnant gets pregnant again there's two
babies there's an older one and a
younger one and the woman has the first
baby the other one sticks around and
she's still pregnant for even longer I
assume is an anxiety dream but it does
actually make the one check something
out real quick here ah you can't it's a
real date exists I thought I was making
a joke you guys it's called super-fit
asian and it's when your body
accidentally releases another egg and
then that I gets fertilized it if it's
early enough in the pregnancy both of
the eggs can become babies or at the
same time but different ages gestational
e what what's aw man double pregnant but
anyway so I wake up from this dream I
can't move I'm a little bit confused
about where exactly I am cuz I'm on the
wrong side of the bed but then my
movement comes back except for the first
time in my life one arm my right arm
does not come back and this does not
mesh with what I understand about sleep
paralysis so what I'm gonna freak it out
and I reach over to see and here's
what's after during my weird double
pregnancy dream I have done this just
shoved my arm down my pants so that's
why I couldn't move it stuck in my pants
new topic now as I was reading the
comments on your most recent video I
noticed it had a couple of thoughts
first yeah our outfit so you may have
noticed you may not have that for two
weeks in a row John and I wore the same
outfit not as each other like the thing
where you go to work the next morning
they're like oh I wore this yesterday
didn't I that's embarrassing
except of course with 250,000 people
watching there were conspiracy theories
about this that John and I had both
pre-taped videos and now we're off on
some secret adventure thing no in fact
and now it is the third week of us
wearing the same outfits the first two
weeks actually this is the case
it seems unlikely we did not do that on
purpose John wore the same shirt two
videos in a row I wore the same shirt
and jacket two videos in a row this week
we did it just to continue messing with
you so sorry about that another thing I
was really struck by in the comments of
your video is how many people don't know
about all the stuff that we do and of
course because we've done a lot of
things over the last ten years and we
are currently doing a lot of things we
got VidCon in Europe Australia and
California coming out we're working on a
new scishow channel with the topic to be
chosen by patreon patrons 10th
anniversary nerd got nerdfighteria to
plan a wife to kill and Gilder to frame
for it not actually killing my wife as
the Princess Bride
reference building how to vote
continuing dear Hank and John
occasionally snapchatting helping found
the internet creators guild which has
done a great job of explaining why the D
monetization thing isn't the end of
YouTube isn't the end of everything you
want to read about that there's a link
in the description it reminds me as I
tend to be reminded about once a year
that I don't always understand this
community as well as I could and the
first time I realize that is when we
created the first nerdfighteria census
in 2013 and I realize now that maybe I'm
having the sensation because it's been
another year since there's been a census
and I haven't done another one and so
yes it is time I spent the five hours
before recording this video putting
together the nerdfighteria census for
2016 it's a pretty involved survey there
are lots of questions we want to get a
really good deep understanding of the
people in this community so that we know
better what to create what you want from
us and what we should do together it's
hugely important to me into John and
it's very important for this community
if you have the time to go take the
census please please do as much
appreciated John I'll see you on Tuesday
double pregnant double the fun linked to
the citizen the description